en 1821 le géant des mathématiques
augustin yoshi publie son cours d'
analyse de l'école polytechnique en
préface de ce livre remarquable cauchy
déplore le manque de rigueur des
mathématiques de son temps et annonce
qu'il publie là le premier ouvrage d
analyse vraiment rigoureux sur que non
j'ai lu une partie du bouquin de kochi
et le niveau de rigueur dedans et à
peine celui du lycée en france
aujourd'hui en particulier si vous
faîtes ce que fait cochet l'université
ou en prépa vous ferez malheur défoncé
par vos profs et ce manque de rigueur un
coût énorme
en effet dans ce cours d' analyse cauchy
à prouver et enseigner des théorèmes fau
l'un des théorèmes faut de kochi dit
qu'une somme infinie de fonctions
continuent et continuent mais nils abel
contredit cauchy en donnant l'exemple
d'une étrange sommes infinie de sinus
qui était exactement égal à des dents de
scie or et signent sous parfaite on
continue mais les dents de scie où
clairement beaucoup de discontinuité les
dents de scie forme donc une fonction
discontinue qui est pourtant son infinie
de fonction tout parfaitement continue
donc coché s'est trompé mais il ne faut
pas trop lui en vouloir
en fait ces sommes infinie de sims et de
cosinus sont vraiment très très très
déroutante
elles font partie de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'analyse de fourier
laquelle trouve aujourd'hui une quantité
absolument monstrueuse application des
mathématiques pures à l'ingénierie du
son en passant par l'imagerie médicale
la cosmologie la mécanique quantique
informatique et de tout ce que vous
voulez mais pour être honnête avec vous
même si je comprends les outils qui sont
utilisés pour faire de l'analyse de
fleurier ces sommes infinie des sinus et
de cosinus semble encore complètement
échappé à ma compréhension
commençons par quelques étrangetés des
séries de fourier c'est à dire ces
sommes infinie de sinus et de cosinus
dont la période divise une période
fondamentale tôt vous riez affirma que
toutes les fonctions périodique de
période de taux était somme d'une série
de fourier et là on a envie de rétorquer
que c'est débile puisque les sinus et
déco smith ont des fonctions bien lisse
bien régulière et tout alors que on peut
construire des fonctions qui sont
complètement biscornus et des
discontinuités dans tous les sens dans
dix ans cela on ne fait que suivre les
traces poussiéreuses de kochi qui plus
est fou rire montra comment déterminer
précisément la série de foyers d'une
fonction en particulier les coefficients
de fourier s'obtiennent à l'aide d'une
jolie formule qui intègre le produit
d'une fonction par le bond sinus ou le
bon caussinus si vous ne comprenez pas
cette formule ce n'est pas grave ce que
je veux souligner là c'est que la
décomposition de fourier correspond à
une équation d'une simplicité
remarquable
sauf que contrairement à ce que disait
fourier toutes les fonctions périodiques
ne peuvent en fait pas être décomposée
en somme de signifier qu'au siège il
aura fallu tout un siècle pour qu'on
comprenne mieux quelles fonctions et est
décomposable en série de fourier en 1907
fatou rice et fisher montre que les
fonctions que les séries de fourier
décrivent sont exactement celles dites
que carey intégrables toutes ces
fonctions sont alors égale à leur série
de fruits vins font en fait faire super
gaffe à ce que l'on veut dire quand on
dit que nous sommes un fini de sinus et
de cosinus est égale à une autre
fonction d'un épisode 2 je vous avais
dit qu'une somme infinie de nombre était
égal à une certaine quantité si les
sommes partielles se rapprochait de la
quantité en question d'un truc assez
sommes partielles peuvent être
étonnamment étrange et pas si proche de
la fonction tentation censé se
rapprocher c'est ce que l'on appelle
l'effet de gips ou effets de bord qui
avait totalement échappé aux
mathématiciens du 19e siècle sur la
figure à l'écran on a une courbe bleue
qui est la fonction qu'ils ont cherché à
calculer avec une série de fourier ici
c'est une fonction en escalier
les courbes rouges sont les sommes
partielles successifs de la série de
fourier qui sont donc censés se
rapprocher de la courbe bleue mais quand
on y regarde de plus près on voit qu'au
niveau des discontinuités les
approximations de fourier ou plutôt
tendance à s'éloigner de la courbe bleue
or pour certaines applications notamment
physique où il ne faut pas que
l'approximation de fourier prennent des
amplitudes énorme
ceci peut être vraiment problématique en
termes mathématiques on dit que la série
de fourier ne convergent pas selon la
norme infinie mais à l inverse il y a un
sens précis selon lequel la série de
faux et d'une fonction va être
véritablement égal à la fonction elle
même pour ceux qui connaissent cette au
sens de la norme dite l2 ou oxy'jeunes
je ne veux pas entrer dans les détails
mais il faut comprendre que l'égalité
entre eux une fonction et sa série de
fourier dépend fortement du sens que
l'on donne au signe égal et en
particulier au sens que l'on donne aux
mots proximité l'étude rigoureuse de
tout ça appartient ce que l'on appelle
l'analyse fonctionnelle
c'est super difficile mais ça peut être
super critique pour certaines
applications
bref vous voulez que les séries de
foyers c'est déjà super compliqué et
pourtant c'est ultra restrictives
puisqu'on a ajouté la uniquement
d'essonne de sinus et de cosinus dont la
période divise une certaine période
fondamentale que se passe-t-il
maintenant si j'ajoute tous les sinus et
tous les caussinus de toutes les
périodes imaginables réponse tes trucs
ultra déroutant
l'addition de toutes les périodes doit
alors se faire à l'aide d'une sorte de
somme continûment infinie que l'on
appelle une intégrale dans le cas de
l'analyse de fourier il s'agit d'écrire
une fonction f comme lost found
continuum de sinus et de cosinus où
chaque sinus et chaque caussinus est
multiplié par des coefficients ados y et
b2 y cette somme continue mon infinie de
sinus et de cosinus pondéré forme ce que
je vais appeler l'intégrale de fourier
et intégra de faux et c'est quelque
chose de super bizarre en fait l'un des
théorèmes les plus surprenants que je
connais des mathématiques est la
conclusion stupéfiante de fourier au
sujet de ces intégrales qui a été
formalisée éprouvé rigoureusement par
plancherel en 1910 voici ce que dit ce
théorème époustouflant toute fonction
quittant suffisamment vite vers zéro à
l'infini est égale à une somme
continûment infinie de sinus et de
cosinus plus précisément et à l'instar
du théorème doris fischer plancherel
montre suffit que la fonction soit de
cars et intégrables pour qu'elles soient
ainsi égal à son intégrale de fourier
qui plus est comme dans le cas des
séries de foyers les coefficients à deux
grecs b2 grec de l'intégrale de fourier
peuvent être déterminées à l'aide de
jolies formules qui ne sont autres que
les intégrales de foyers elle même c'est
coefficient 1 des grecs les p2 y sont
alors en fait des fonctions qui sont des
sortes de représentations dual d'une
autre fonction f et que l'on appelle les
transformée de fourier de la fonction f
à l'instar de là
f mm ces coefficients sont donc eux
aussi des sommes continus infinis de
cygnus et de cosinus les détails sont
super technique mais le message final
est absolument stupéfiant toute fonction
kit ont suffisamment vite vers zéro à
l'infini est une somme infinie de
fonction qui elle ne tente jamais vers
zéro à l'infini
en fait ces fonctions même qui composent
la fonction d'origine qui tourne vers
zéro ses fonctions qui sont les sinus et
les caussinus eux ne peuvent pas être
écrits comme des sommes infiniment
continue de sinus et de cosinus et we ll
ne tend pas vers zéro à l'infini
alors on pourrait croire que tous cru
raconte là c'est juste des technicalités
qui n'intéressent que des maths et
pourtant tout ceci se trouve au coeur de
la théorie la plus fondamentales de la
physique d'aujourd'hui la mécanique
quantique dans cette théorie une
particule est forcément une
superposition de vitesse et de position
à tout instant la superposition de
position à ce que l'on appelle la
fonction d'onde c'est quelque chose qui
varient dans l'espace et en gros les
endroits là fonctionnons de prendre des
grandes valeurs dans l'espace sont les
endroits où une particule a plus de
présence et bien à transformer de la
fonction d'onde d'une particule est sa
superposition de vitesse je vous renvoie
vers cette excellente vidéo de sciences
étonnante et cet autre excellente vidéo
de looking glass universe
pour en savoir plus sauf que l'analyse
de fourier montre que plus une particule
localiser puis ça veut dire que sa
présence à l'infini et très rapidement
très proche de zéro et ça ça veut dire
qu'elle doit être une somme de beaucoup
de s'initier de cosinus puisque chacun
des souvenirs cd caussinus est
infiniment est allé dans l'espace pour
faire un truc localiser faut vraiment on
ajouté vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
autrement dit la transformée de fourier
de la fonction d'onde qui répertorie en
gros tous les sinus il est caussinus qui
contribue à former la fonction d'onde
s'est transformée de fourier va
forcément être très étalée puisqu'elle
correspond à beaucoup de sinus et de
cosinus et ça ça revient à dire qu'une
autre particule va être composée de
beaucoup de vitesse différentes
à l'inversé une particule est composé de
peu de vitesse ça veut dire que sa
fonction d'onde est une superposition de
peu de sinus de cosinus ça ça veut dire
qu'elle roos
en gros pas mal à dessiner cité
caussinus qui sont très étalées à
travers l'espace ce dont je vous parle
la cdu principe d'incertitude de
heisenberg même si moi personnellement
je déteste cette terminologie et je
préfère appeler ça le principes
d'étalement de heisenberg car au fond ce
que dit ce principe c'est qu'une
particule ne peut pas être à la fois une
superposition de très peu de positions
et de très peu de vitesse soit son
étalement dans l'espace est assez grand
soit c'est son étalement en vitesse qui
est assez grand en conclusion j'aimerais
bien récapituler un peu cette histoire
assez folle de l'analyse de fourier au
début du 17ème siècle c'était avant tout
une source de bizarreries mathématiques
qui permettait de construire des objets
mystérieux est assez incompréhensible et
tout ça ça motive énormément de
recherches pour plus de rigueur
mathématique qui tout au long du dix
neuvième siècle aura amené à l'analyse
moderne et tout ça ça a préparé le
terrain pour qu'au xxème siècle on est
enfin une compréhension plus poussée de
ces bizarreries mathématiques et c'est à
ce moment là que les mathématiques était
enfin prête à être utilisée pour
développer une nouvelle théorie
révolutionnaire de la physique la
mécanique quantique
que de chemin parcouru et je vous le
promets on est loin d'en avoir vu le
bout
l'anr fois on a parlé des nombreux
ordinaux trans fini et vous avez été
nombreux à me signifie qu'on n'avait pas
tout compris à la vidéo précédente
première chose à dire si vous n'avez pas
tout compris c'est parfaitement normal
la plupart de mes vidéos sont très
difficiles à comprendre en premier
visage c'est tout à fait normal ne pas
avoir tout compris et mon but c'est pas
vouziers tout compris en une urne un
visionnage
alors ça peut surprendre certains
d'entre vous mais je pense qu'en fait
c'est très important de laisser en
suspens certaines choses de comprendre
qu'on n'a pas tout compris et d'avoir
surtout quelque chose que l'on peut
méditer chez soi après la vidéo c'est
vraiment mon but recherché c'est que
continuer à réfléchir après avoir vu la
vidéo
et pour cela le mieux mon sens c'est
peut-être dur psychologiquement mais je
pense que mieux c'est vraiment de
comprendre qu'on n'a pas tout compris
qu'il ya des choses
on peut méditer et c'est pour ça que
vous ne comprenez pas tout mais vidéo
basse et même appréciable et j'espère
surtout que vous ne paniquez pas moi ou
vous n'avez pas tout compris
ça c'est très normal de ne pas avoir
tout compris il n'y a pas d'examen qui
vient après de toute façon par contre je
vais m'excuser pour la vidéo précédente
parce que je pense que certains passages
n'avait pas lieu d'être dans la vidéo
parce qu'ils étaient trop compliqué
pense que sur les ordis nos jeux me suis
laissé un petit peu emporter parce que
notamment effigie et sens étonnante
avait déjà fait des vidéos surtout ali j
puis vice aussi avait fait des superbes
vidéos qui introduisait déjà les
ordinaux du coup je me suis dit que
c'était déjà sur internet j'avais pas
répéter ce qu'ils avaient dû répéter je
voulais aller un petit peu plus loin et
j'ai tendance est à supposer que vous
êtes tous déjà vu el djir
c'est peut-être une erreur de ma part
mais vraiment aller voir ali j allais
voir cette vidéo ça va vous permettre de
bien mieux comprendre ma vidéo ensuite
puis surtout c'est un super compliment
il prouve aussi des trucs et on bien
plus loin que ma vidéo âmes 74,1 alain
roger et matthieu morando on pose des
questions sur les autres opérations que
l'on pourrait faire entre des trucs
infinie alors tout d'abord il faut que
je vous dise qu'il ya les nombreux
cardinaux aussi qu'ils peuvent être
ajoutés et multiplier et on peut aussi
faire des expériences à sion des
cardinaux mais en fait les cardinaux
c'est assez boeing mais j'ai envie au
niveau des calculs arithmétiques
notamment l'addition est la même chose
que la multiplication si je fais un
infini cardinal plus notre infinie
cardinal sarr est égal ou premier
infinie cardinal fois le deuxième
infinie cardinal il nous sommes en fait
ça va être tout simplement le plus grand
des deux infinis
l'arithmétique des cardinaux s'en fait
quelque chose de vraiment boeing
qu'arithmétique les ordinaux ça c'est
super cool un sandwich et à dia et dans
l'épisode 1 de cette série sur à
l'infini vous avait parlé d'une
opération assez étrange qui étaient les
flèches s'appelle les flashs de knut et
matthieu morando se pose la question de
quel est le nombre commune obtient si on
fait par exemple au méga flèche au melia
texas avait comme une option ce média si
on fait un méga flèche flèche aux médias
là on va obtenir oméga flèche omega
flash media frechaut mega-cd sud est
infinie et ça ça va être aux médias
puissance au milieu et ça on a dit que
c'était spécial 0 maintenant qu'est ce
que l'on obtient en spray oméga flèche
flèche flash media l'agent ça c'est un
truc qui est certainement très très très
très très grand je suis même pas sûr que
l'on puisse les clients en termes
d'epsilon mais on peut même aller plus
loin comme le propose matthieu morando
et définir aux médias flèche avec oméga
flèche et avec un méga au bout et là on
obtient un truc est vraiment archi méga
gigantesque mais ce sera encore plus
petits comédiens puisque si on définit
les flèches de knut poseurs dhainaut
comme ça ça restera un ordinale dénombre
à 10 ans qui sera précédé la nombre
dénombrable d'éléments je suis un kikoo
lol et alain roger sans surprise du
théorème de gensan qui donc prouve la
consistance de l'arithmétique de p and o
et ça c'est super étrange si on connaît
le deuxième théorème d'incomplétude
google qui dit que l'arithmétique de
bennoo ne peut pas prouver sa propre
consistance faty l'arithmétique de paix
à noël ne peut pas approuver la tournée
currence trans fini jusqu'à l'ordinateur
piscine 0 qu'utilise kenson pour prouver
la consistance de l'arithmétique de
piano du coup on sort du cadre de
théorème d'incomplétude de gödel
puisqu'on est en train de parler des de
l'arithmétique de piano avec une théorie
qui est à l'extérieur de l'arithmétique
de pernaut c'est pour ça que c'est des
médecins la thématique
ceci étant dit il ya beaucoup de gens
notamment en éveil le qui détestait
l'infini qui a pas mal critiqués de
théorème de ghayne scène en disant que
n'utilise une récurrence qui est plus
forte que le rythme éthique de p and o
pour prouver à grossissant d'opium
du coup que c'était un petit peu débile
comme raisonnement en fait c'est pas
tout à fait des bilans ya un truc en
plus comme le théorème de gamsen puisque
light meetic primitive récursive plus
cette récurrence trans fini jusqu'à
l'option zéro ne permettent pas de
construire
l'arithmétique de piano n implique pas
tout l'arithmétique du père noël
implique uniquement la consistance de
rythme éthique de piano tout c'est
quelque chose de très subtil qu'il
faisait dire en tout cas haagensen que
ça a été suffisant que c'était mieux
qu'on puisse faire pour être confiant en
la consistance de l'arithmétique de p
and o en reparlera beaucoup plus en
détail tout ça quand on parlera de
rythme évident de perdre et puis ensuite
du théorème de gueule mais bien sûr tout
ça ça pose la question de l'existence à
l'origine des ordinaux et ce sont les
questions que pose jhb v et michel
l'ombre or il ya la réponse de base
c'est que on peut toujours définir des
théories mathématiques dans lequel ces
ordinaux existe du coup il existera du
coup dans un monde mathématiques aims
par exemple d'un élève ses soutiens à
part parler de celle ci dans cette série
mais j ai je rêvé
michel en main et à l'instar de d'autres
parmi vous dans les commentaires
semble dire que ceci n'existe que dans
un monde de mathématiques qu'il fallait
dans son dos mathématiques pour croire
c'est peut-être vrai parce que c'est une
question philosophique partir de ce
moment-là tout logique où je sais pas
trop comment la pièce à savoir si ils
existent vraiment c'est ordinaux dans le
monde réel ce que je dirais c'est que
faut pas être trop prompt et rejeter
l'existence de ces objets dans le monde
réel
je pense qu'à la physique du 20e siècle
nous on nous a vraiment montré que le
monde
réel est bien plus compliqué bien plus
étrange bien plus contre intuitif que ce
qu'on pourrait croire naïvement donc
soyons vraiment prudent quand on parle
du monde réel
einstein personne ne pensait que la
géométrie non euclidienne s'applique est
vraiment au monde réel et avant fait une
main une personne ne pensait que les
séries infinie divergentes allait avoir
une quelconque utilité pour étudier le
monde réel en fait il se trouve qu'elles
sont super utile donc peut-être que
c'est hordinois seront un jour très
utile pour étudier la physique
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
avec franchement on va parler d'un truc
encore plus bizarre qui sont les courbes
qui remplissent le plan cours de piano
et de gilberte autre chose on atteint ou
va atteindre les 10 mille abonnés sa
vidéo sur internet si ce sera le cas
et du coup comme je vous l'avais promis
dans sa sphère une faq vous invite à
mettre toutes vos questions dans les
commentaires ou sur twitter en utilisant
le hashtag faq cette forme et puis c'est
à dire quelque chose comme jeudi
je vais essayer de sortir cette vidéo a
vaincu si vous avez aimé cet épisode
français le lac est le commentaire de
partager tout ça vous a beau nous
pondent pas manqué mais plusieurs
épisodes versé au type r pardon et
j'espère que vous la prochaine fois
winnipeg est exact c'est un match et que
des expériences chose monique à chicago
derrick brooks laich